uh so this is the second talk of this
afternoon session and i'd like to
introduce aditi lada
who will be speaking about work with
intel and santosh on algorithms for
sampling convex bodies
uh okay
uh right
so uh in this talk i'm going to go over
um two different very different
algorithms for
sampling convex bodies uh so first one
is coordinated and run and the second is
called weighted they can block
uh so
before starting the problem here is uh
we're given just a membership article
access to a convict's body case so like
uh just an article which tells you
whether the given point is inside the
body or not and the goal is to generate
a nearly uniform sample from k
so
this problem is a
basic uh ingredient for a lot of
algorithms for like optimization
integration volume computation etc
and
the
very classic approach to this problem is
to just design an
ergotic reversible markov chain
whose state space is the convex body and
whose stationary distribution is the
desired uh distribution that we want to
sample from
and uh the important question is to
bound the rate of conversions of this
markov chain so uh two of the most
versatile algorithms for this which work
for any complex body in general and also
for uh
sampling log concave distributions
restricted to convex bodies are uh ball
walk and hit and run
and uh their mixing time is order n
square r square uh
where r you can think of r as like the
diameter of the body uh given that it
contains a unit ball
uh from a warm start uh
sorry what
n is the ambient dimension so we're
talking about
rn uh
okay uh so
i'm just defining conductance as
conductance because we'll be using these
quantities again and again so
conductance is just the probability of
escaping
any subset of the body in one step at
the uniform distribution uh normalized
by the
weight of the subset and uh s
conductance is uh
analogous to conductance but only for
subsets with size at least s
so only large subsets and both of these
quantities uh can be used to bound the
mixing time of
a reversible markov chain uh so this is
the classic theorem by lovation
shimanovics which
bounds the
mixing time in terms of both conductance
and s conductance for
when s is
epsilon by 2m where epsilon is the
target error that we're uh
aiming for
uh okay
so uh now i'm going to talk about uh
coordinate hit and run
um
so uh
this algorithm is uh
it is uh extremely simple as you'll see
in the next slide and it has been around
since 1971 it was proposed by turchin
and it's inspired by uh statistical
physics and is commonly used for uh b
sampling as well as bayesian inference
however
no polynomial uh bound on its mixing
time was known
and
but it's still used in practice uh
sometimes over a while walk due to its
efficiency uh
and simplicity uh so
coordinate hit and run is uh simply at
the current point uh you select one of
the coordinate axes
uniformly at random
and then uh
from the chord
formed at that point
uh you move to any point on that chord
uniformly at random and you just i trade
uh repeat that step uh t times
uh
so
one thing that makes this algorithm
appealing is that at in one step you're
only changing one coordinate of the
current point
uh right and so like in terms of
polytope uh
it it reduces the computation to like
moving to a random point
the computation would be order mn it
reduces it to order m because we just
need to check one column
uh
can i just ask is the little t fixed
sorry what is this
in the step
uh
that is sorry that's just a line the the
that's the chord so you're moving uh
to any point on that uh
chord uh it should be intersection with
the convex body uh
uh
so uh our main result uh uh along with
my advisor santosh foreign is
so what's the
just
the second step
so is it that you sample from a whole
real line and see whether that point is
inside the
polytube or you find the two end points
of that line and then make sure your t
is in there
so you find the two end points of the
line and then uh
select uniformly uh select a point t
between those two points
okay sure thank you
so is there some sort of logarithmic
cost associated like do you do some sort
of bisection search to identify yes yeah
yes you can uh assume like a logarithmic
cost in the diameter but uh uh
that causes subsume by like the other uh
factors so that cost doesn't dominate
okay
uh okay uh
so
uh for any convex body containing a unit
ball and uh it being mostly contained in
a ball of radius capital r
uh the mixing time of coordinated run is
uh of the order
n to the nine r square so here the star
term subsumes uh
l
polynomial
and logarithmic terms in the warm start
parameter and uh
at the error parameter
uh
so
concurrently with this result uh
naran
and shivastava also uh gave a proof of
uh mixing of this uh coordinated run for
uniform uh bodies which uh
was of the other oyster into the seven r
one to the four so here r1 is the l
infinity uh
radius of the ball containing the body
uh
sorry
good question i didn't quite understand
why the the per duration complexity was
ofm could you uh explain this again
uh
sorry so that that was uh just an
example like uh
why it could possibly be simpler uh
at first sight it would appear that
using this algorithm would be faster or
more efficient because
if you're given an uh explicit
description of a positive like ax
greater than b
then when you're changing the uh that
when you're moving to the next step you
need to check whether that uh step or
when you're finding this chord you need
to check whether certain points are
inside the
set or not so if you were moving in any
random direction you'd probably have to
recompute the ax
the vector ax right but if you were just
changing one coordinate you just need to
add one column to your um
your current calculation for ax
i i see so like improving this
progression complexity requires like
keeping around like extra information uh
and like updating it or something to to
make the whole thing faster
uh yes i mean uh you would have the
yes you can assume you have like the ax
for the current point of x given
explicit description of the politic
okay thank you
okay
[Music]
okay
no no it's from warm start sorry i
should have mentioned very clearly also
the uh
factor for the monster is actually
polynomial here so it's not even
logarithmic uh
okay uh so now
uh
proving the mixing time uh for this
random walk uh so this standard proof
while using conductance is to go through
a one-stop coupling argument that just
says that if two points are close to
each other in some metric then their
one-step distributions are also closed
and
this reduces the conductance to like a
purely um
geometric argument that's the
isoparametry which says that if two
subsets of the body are really far from
each other then the volume of the
remaining uh body
is proportional to the distance between
these two subsets
so uh
okay
well uh
one so
we can start by trying to do some
one-step coupling for coordinate hit and
run
so it's just saying that x and y
are closed in some metric
and this should imply that like the
their one-step distribution should also
be closed
however uh for the case of coordinate
hit and run if you consider these two
points which
all of their coordinates are different
then uh
they they can be arbitrarily closed uh
however their one-stop distributions
almost don't overlap
so uh
this is uh this this issue uh
led us to
define a different notion of being uh
separable uh suds being separable from
each other
uh
which is
access disjoint subsets so two subsets
are called axis disjoint
if any two points in them share at most
one coordinate
so uh
in more in more simple terms it means
that any axis parallel line
can
either pass through uh s1 or s2 it
cannot uh intersect both of them
or you cannot move from uh any point in
s1 to any point in s2 in one step of
coordinate hit and run
uh
okay
so
now uh
this gives an analogous uh one-step
coupling argument uh
which says that uh
take any partition of a convex body uh
so that's s1 and s2 here
and
find subsets with the within those um
sets which have very low probability of
escaping them so espen dash has
probability of escaping s1 that is
moving to s2 is less than 1 by 2n and
similarly for s2 dash
so
this implies that
s1 dash and s2 dash are axis disjoint
um
so uh the proof is just this picture
which says that if a cord does pass
through both s1 dash and s2 dash then
its
total length should actually be its
length uh
with the intersection of espen dash plus
the intersection of ester dash should
actually be less
less than the length of its intersection
with the comics body which is
not true
so um
this uh leads to the next point is uh
now now if we can just give an
isoparametric inequality for access
disjoint subsets then
we'll have a proof for mixing time of
coordinated and run
so uh
as a first step uh
we restrict the convex body k to just
cubes axis align cubes
and uh
for any axis aligned cube and
and any axis disjoint subsets as when an
s2
uh the volume of the remaining cube is
at least
log 2 by n times minimum of the volume
of these two subsets
so
we'll use this to build uh build an
isoparametric inequality for general
convex sets
so uh
this is a very brief sketch of the proof
uh for
cubes
where uh
you have a projection operation
and then extension operation so
given any subset
s
you
projection just means that you project
it on a face of the cube and extension
means that uh any subset you take any
subset of a face of the cube and just
extend it along uh it's normal
so the interesting thing about these two
operations is that
if you
if s1 and s2 are axis disjoint and if
you start with
s1 and apply a
projection and then extend that
projection
the resulting
set that uh that we get would be
completely contained in
s1 and s3 so where s3 is just the
remainder of the body because s1 and s2
are axis disjoint
so
uh just
just saying that the volume of these
projections is large is enough to prove
the isoparametry for n cubes
and for that we use the
lumis with whitney inequality which just
says the product of
projections is uh large than uh the
volume of the subset uh to the n minus
one
um
so
now for general bodies uh uh we get
the isoparametric inequality is the
volume of s3 is
s times n to the minus 3.5 uh
divided by r times uh the minimum so
this is uh
a this is kind of an uh this would lead
to an s conductance uh argument where
here s is just uh
any any parameter smaller than the size
of the minimum of the two subsets
so uh
and
the proof uh
for this is again because we know how to
do this for cubes we
are going to place a grid on them
on the space
uh of size
n to the minus
s times n to the minus three by two
and then just account for uh all the
mass of s3 that uh we'll get from
these cubes so we are only interested in
two kinds of cubes uh so first cubes
that intersect s1 and
uh the volume of their intersection with
s1 is less than
two thirds of the volume
of this cube and the other is just those
that intersect s1 and the volume of
intersection is greater than two-thirds
of the cube
so uh i'm going to cheat a little bit
because in reality this uh cube
these cubes might not be completely
contained in this convex body case so
we'll need to work with the contraction
of the convex body
by alpha
but the argument is
pretty standard so i'm just going to
uh
continue with this
uh so
like the first case would be at least
half of the volume in s1
is in the cubes of
type 1 c1 so that's the good case right
because then we can individually apply
uh
cube isoparametry to all these cubes and
get
s3 proportional to s1
uh and
the other case would be
when at least half of s1 is in uh
c2 so
c2 are the tubes that mostly contain s1
then
so in that case uh the boundary of this
set of keeps c2 would be large
due to just euclidean isopymetry in
convex bodies
and so working on cubes around this
boundary uh we can get a lot of s3 from
those cubes
and so this was a very high level uh
outline of the
proof of general isoparametry
but
now that we have general isoparametry uh
we can prove a bound on s conductance uh
so
this is
starting with any set s1 uh
whose volume is at least s and less than
half
uh
find these subsets s1 dash and s2 dash
those are subsets of very low
probability of escaping
and if both of them are small then we
are done because then the probability of
escaping s1 is uh big
but if both of them are large then the
probability of moving from s1 to s2 plus
the probability of moving from s2 to s1
b which are equal because this is a
reversible chain it would be
proportional to the volume of this set
s3
uh that we have
and uh from isoparametry the volume of
s3 is large and so just
uh this implies that the probability of
escaping s1 would be large and this
balance the s conductance of this markov
chain
uh okay
so
now
uh
open problems for so there uh
for this would be uh the isoparametric
coefficient for just the cubes that we
saw previously
uh currently we proved that it is log 2
by n
but b conjecture that it is actually
just a constant log 2.
uh
and uh the second is what's the correct
mixing time of coordinated run
so uh in our paper we uh show that this
example
uh which is just
a body with an angle with the two axis
and uh whose each each cross section is
an n simplex
the conductance uh for coordinated run
for this body is uh
at most one by n square r
so uh if you compare this with ball walk
and hit and run uh both of them have
conductance at least one by nr for any
for even for this body so this strongly
suggests that
the mixing time for
coordinated and run is actually worse
than uh walking hit and run in the worst
case
okay
so
this concludes the coordinate hit and
run part
now
we can just ask if there are any
questions before you moved on to the
second part
any questions on
can can you explain a little bit
rational on the iso premature inequality
the 3.5
exponent oh okay so uh yes it uh
yeah so it went from like 1 by n to n to
the minus 3.5 right uh so the
this uh
this is mainly due to breaking it down
into a grid
because uh
when we want all the cubes in uh
when we want all the cubes in the
contraction to be inside the body too we
really have to decrease this uh
delta the size of cubes in the grid to
be
like n to the minus 1.5 and the other n
comes because uh
here we are over counting some mass
n times so we have to like normalize up
by n so
uh yes the end to the 3.5 is mainly
the
mainly due to breaking this into a grid
thanks
anyone else
okay go ahead
uh okay so
the
uh in in this session uh we're just
going to restrict
to polytopes and
we'll also assume that we're given the
explicit description of the polytope
uh
so
well balwa can hit and run
do work with polytubes they are not a
fine invariant because they their
runtime their mixing time depends on the
diameter of the body
uh so they need a an expensive step to
bring the body to an isotropic position
so alternatively uh
people have studied uh
walks where uh where instead of uh
using uh like the same ball for every
point
we can define
an ellipsoid uh based on the structure
of the complex body so uh given a convex
function f
uh on the polytope uh
let so i'm just going to use this
h everywhere for the hessian f or
just a matrix function h
so uh the
this function defines an ellipsoid on
every point in the
polytube uh
so
this leads to a
natural walk in which
at the current point uh you pick a point
uh y uniformly at random from the this
ellipsoid of radius r
centered at the current point
and then
uh if
x also belongs to the ellipsoid of that
point uh you move to y
with probability minimum of one times
the ratio of the volumes so uh the last
term is the just the metropolis hastings
term to ensure that the stationary
distribution of this walk would be
uniform
and uh that it will be reversible
and uh and just repeat this step two
times can i ask you is that is the f a
barrier function for this polytope uh
yes so it goes to infinity at the
boundaries yes okay thanks
okay
so uh
for just for the problem this problem of
uh
sampling
uh
uniformly sampling poly tubes uh this is
just uh
all the previous work uh about the
mixing rate and per stop cost
so um
in this talk i'm just going to talk
about the result a second from
last result which
uh talks about the weight that they can
walk and its mixing rate which is and
square
uh
i should also mention this is not
currently the best thing to do for
polytopes
it's actually
using fast wawa plus rounding which has
a
time complexity of mn to the 3.2 and it
doesn't even need a warm start this
uh
last point okay
so
uh
this is
some notation that uh i'm going to be
using again and again which is uh
ax is just the constraint matrix
weighted by the inverse of
slags for every constraint
and uh
the local norm is just the norm induced
by the this h matrix function
uh okay so
uh
it
when you considered uh dickenbach with
the barrier function as the log barrier
uh its session is uh this matrix ax
transpose ax and uh kanan and narayanan
proved that the mixing time of uh they
can walk with the lock barrier is
order m n
uh
so
it it this is linearly dependent on m
the number of inequalities uh
in the description of the polytube so
uh
this dependence on m is also tight
so as an example uh take this hypercube
and just duplicate the top base of this
hypercube multiple times in your
description
uh the volume of the diction
ellipsoid uh
when the face was given just one time to
when the face was repeated like six
times decreases for most points so uh
that affects the step size of of the
walk
uh so
this is just that if someone just gave
you a description of a politic with like
a lot of linear dependence between the
constraints or some constraints uh just
repeated multiple times
uh the runtime of this walk would be
affected uh
so
the idea to improve upon uh
to get rid of this linear dependence on
m is to weight away the constraints
uh so that the sum of this weights uh is
still order n
uh
so go from something like ax transpose
ax to ax transpose w x ax where w x is a
diagonal matrix matrix of the weights
and
ideally you'd want
this wxi so the weight of the ith
constraint
to be proportional to the its leverage
score of the ayat through in
the
in uh square root w x a x uh so that it
reflects how important that uh row is in
the
constraint matrix at x
so uh turns out there is a barrier
function which satisfies exactly that
property
uh
so uh
the this is the least output barrier
function uh
it's used in interior point uh
theory to solve uh linear programs
faster uh so i'm not going to parse this
expression uh just
the
uh the point is that uh the weight that
we use uh
for the h matrix is the way that that is
the way that maximizes the lee secretary
function at point x
and uh so the age that actually we're
actually going to use is just some
polylog terms
times uh
ax transpose times this double scale wx
matrix times ax
and so this function is not exactly the
hessian of the least barrier but it's
very closely related to the hessian and
also it's still a finite variant
so okay
now uh i'm going to
state the main result of our uh paper
oh no sorry
the so uh
the
the reason why this uh
barrier function
is used uh
is because of self-concordance so this
is a little detour into interior point
theory
so any a matrix function h is called
self-put current if it's
derivative
if the spectral norm of its derivative
in any direction h is bounded by the
local norm of h at that point so uh
this property
guarantees conversions with uh newton
method like in uh
in newton uh method
uh and also the two variables that we
saw ls barrier and log barrier are
self-contained so in terms of sampling
the this probability can help the random
walk take large steps in the interior of
the body
while about avoiding the boundary of the
body uh however
this property is not quite enough to
guarantee
mixing time so
we augment this property slightly
so instead of
having spectral norm
we have that the frobenius norm of the
derivative of h is bounded by
the local norm of
a
small h
uh okay
so
if h is self concordant then for any two
points x and y which are close to each
other
uh
their uh h
capital h functions do not change much
in probanious norm as you move from
x to y and um
as an interesting fact uh
both universal and entropic barriers are
strongly self-concordant if the kls
conjecture is true so there's a
self-concordance is implied by the
kayla's architecture
okay
and in addition to stronghold
concordance we need
one more property that's called
new bar symmetry
so a barrier function is called neighbor
symmetric
if
the elf side of radius one is contained
in this uh symmetric intersection of the
bodies at point
x so uh the symmetric
intersection is just
uh k
intersection with 2x minus k so this uh
this set is centered at x
and uh the symmetric intersection is
contained in the
outside of
radius square root nu bar so uh
the this is uh this is called the
symmetric properties uh with the
parameter nu bar
and it
it's helpful in uh
bounding the conductance because it
relates isoparametry to uh like the step
size that you can take
so uh
our our main theorem is that the mixing
rate of taking walk with a newer
symmetric strongly sub-concordant matrix
function with convex log determinant is
bounded by
uh order nu bar
uh
so
this is uh true for
any
any function
uh as an example
if we compare log barrier and the ls
matrix
so a hessian of the log barrier here so
they're both strongly sub-concordant uh
however their new bar parameters are
different
so
it's m for the log barrier and
n times and polylog factors in m
for the ls matrix and they are both they
both have convex log determinants so
using this result uh the mixing time of
log barrier is
order mn and the mixing time using ls
matrix
is order and square
okay
so
i
am
i'm going to go over a very brief
outline of the proof of this theorem
um
okay
so
so
again we'll start with the one-step
coupling uh argument
it's uh so
here strong self-concordance implies
that if x and y are closing the local
norm
their distance is bounded by
r by square root n then uh the total
variation distance between the one step
distributions is
bounded by a constant so three by four
um
and uh to prove this we use the standard
triangular inequality
so here uh p x and p y are the actual
one step distributions induced after
doing the rejection step
and e x and e y are just the
uniform distributions on the ellipsoids
at x and y
so uh
the first step uh so the middle the
middle point uh the middle step is just
on uh
on the uniform distributions the first
two terms can be bounded by just
bounding the rejection probability at
every step and uh
we use the convexity of the log
determinant here and
strongs of concordance uh to bound this
rejection probability so it just says
that for most points uh if you're at a
point x
and for most points uh in the ellipsoid
center that x the rejection probability
is
le
sorry the acceptance probability is at
least a constant
so which is enough to bound the
the the first and the third term here
and now uh to bound the middle term here
uh i have expanded these ellipsoids to
actually write their covariance matrix
because we are going to use the
triangular inequality again here
to go from this uh
these two alphas
to these four ellipsoids so the first
picture is just the same ellipsoid
shifted by uh
the local norm of x y
and
the second picture is two ellipsoids uh
centered at the same point so uh the
first a total variation distance is
bounded just by parallel sorry yeah
five okay uh bounded just by purely
geometric arguments because uh these are
just balls separated by radius times
square root n
the same balls so their intersection is
large
and uh for the second picture
because uh
h is a strongly self-concordant function
these two ellipse the eigenvalues of uh
these uh two ellipsoids
have to be pretty close because we've
bounded them in probing frobenious norms
so uh that implies that their
intersection is large uh okay
now uh so finally to bound conductance
uh
we'll use uh this isoparametric
inequality by lowash but says uh
that for any disjoint subsets of a
convex body uh
the volume of the remaining body is at
least uh
so here dk is the cross ratio distance
so cross ratio distance between s1 and
s2 times the product of their volumes
divided by the volume of k
so
because of the symmetry of this barrier
uh we can bound the cross
ratio distance between any two points
uh with the local distance between these
two points divided by the new bar and
just to see this
the idea is that the chord px would be
contained in this big ellipsoid of
radius new bar
and uh
so this gives the final one step
inequality is just that if
two points
are the cross ratio distance between two
points is less than r by square root nu
bar
then the total variation distance
between their one step uh distributions
is less than three by four and
so now we'll just follow a very standard
argument and uh bound the conductance so
this is uh
it for the ellis barrier part uh so some
open problems
are is the mixing time of the dicken
walk with ls matrix actually o star n
so right now we only know that it's at
least n and the upper bound is
order n square uh so
this is uh so the bound is not tight
and
the second part is that uh because this
uh sorry
uh about this mixing time question is
the missing ingredient like uh
isopremetry let's say uh
like a better isoparametry inequality or
something
um
so
possibly yes uh because uh
the
the com none of these uh the components
that we discussed were uh
are tight in the argument so it could be
a combination of those
uh any of these components so it might
be the case here there there's a better
isoparametric inequality
okay thank you
and the second open question is
because we are actually optimizing a
convex function in every step
the computational complexity of every
step is uh m n to the omega minus one so
is it possible to do some
type of amortize amortization to improve
this to um
and n squared plus number of non-zeros
in a uh that mn shouldn't be there uh so
just use uh the fact that the uh matrix
doesn't change much
between uh
consecutive points to
avoid actually computing the new matrix
at every point uh okay
so uh
yeah this is the end of my talk
thank you very much
questions
all right last chance
okay well thanks again
we'll be back i think in half an hour
right for the last two great see you
then